my father firt I don't get life mixed up
with making a living I was there for all
four of my children being born when the
first one was born I recognized the
difference between life and making a
living their life you know our family is
life you know that thing that's making a
living you will fail at some point in
your life accept it you will lose you
will embarrass yourself you will suck at
something there's no doubt about it
embrace it because it's inevitable and I
should know in the acting business you
fail all the time early on in my career
I auditioned for a part in a Broadway
musical perfect role for me I thought
except for the fact that I can't sing so
I'm in the wings I'm about to go onstage
but the guy in front of me he's singing
like Pavarotti just going on and on and
on and I'm just shrinking I'm getting
smaller and smaller so I come out with
my little sheet music and it was it was
just my imagination by the temptations
that's what I came up with so I hand it
to the the the accompany us and she
looks at it and looks at me and looks at
it the director and was like ah I didn't
get the job but here's the thing I
didn't quit I didn't fall back I walked
out of there to prepare for the next
audition and the next audition and the
next audition I pray I pray and I pray
but I continue to fail and fail but it
didn't matter because you know what is
an old saying you hang around the
barbershop long enough sooner or later
you're gonna get a haircut so you will
catch a break and I did catch a break
last year I did a play called fences on
Broadway won the Tony Award and I didn't
have to sing by the way but here's the
kicker he was at the Court Theatre it
was at the same theatre that I failed
that first audition 30 years prior the
point is every graduate here today has
the training and the talent to succeed
but do you have the guts to fail you
just watched two amazing clips from
Denzel Washington take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]